What's up guys welcome back to another epic day of experimenting!
Today I'm with MatPat and we both have gas you know
MatPat what is going on today
So today we are doing some experiment with
sulfur hexafluoride or as we call it SF6
not be confused with Street Fighter 6
all you videogame fans out there
That's right today we're answering a comment
request from GD Nilo932 who says
"Do something with sulfur hexafluoride
plz" so MatPat and I have stepped up
to the challenge to do something with
sulfur hexafluoride and boy howdy are we
doing all sorts of things today your
request has been answered so we've got
an aquarium we've got some balloons
we've got some tanks here can you tell
us briefly what's going on Mat no this
isn't my video all right so this
something you've ever stopped to
consider like if you're living in a
different place a different atmosphere
it might actually change the way that
you talk I've never really stopped to
think about it until just this moment so
we've got a few experiments so we're
going to try today you went down to the
store and picked up this bottle of
helium it did this is just party balloon
helium and it's actually I mean they do
kind of dilute it a little bit there's
20% air in here but guaranteed up to 80% helium so we all know what
happens when you put your mouth over
this take a big suck and try to talk yes
(Singing in a high voice) "Hello my baby, Hello my honey, Hello my ragtime gal"
(Normal voice) So helium makes times less dense than air so what happens is as
you're speaking your vocal chords
vibrate a little bit faster and your
voice sounds higher now there's another
gas that I'm sure you are all familiar
with by now called sulfur hexafluoride
sulfur hexafluoride is actually six
times heavier than air so theoretically
it should have the opposite effect right
this is a tank of sulfur hexafluoride
it's actually the smallest tank I could
purchase it costs me $1,400 and it takes
(MatPat: Humblebrag! Rakin' out the dough!)
I'm just I'm just saying it's not easy stuff
to get and it cost it's about 50
pounds here to lift it up so I think we
got a lifetime supply needless to say
and it's got this thing that protects
the valve so as its rolling around a
truck or whatnot it's not going to
accidentally spill out so let's go ahead
and take the cap off here fill up a
balloon and see what kind of fun we can
have
with SF6 we both have two different
colored balloons here I have a white
balloon my friend Mat has chosen to go
to the
dark side in my balloon is helium gas
which is six times lighter than air
which means (Grant speaking with a high voice) it makes my voice incredibly
high and this is an experiment we're all
familiar with everybody loves helium but
on the other hand (MatPat:) sulfur hexafluoride is
actually six times heavier than air
which means that when I suck it in,
(MatPat speaking with a deep voice) my voice becomes super deep and super intense. Come over and join the dark side!! get to the chopper! to the chopper!
(Normal voice) here's the
experiment one half breath helium one
half breath sulfur hexafluoride what's
going to happen that's my usual charming
everyday Midwestern voice grant that's
clearly what's going to happen here so
this is me its a me mario now its a me mario hey that
was actually fairly normal it does
actually sound very normal slightly too much of this but overall
kind of balances out hey its a me mario ho! this stuff is actually heavier than air so it sits in
your lungs you can actually hear my
voice is going through a little bit
transition point right now like he's
going through puberty because the gas
won't come out of your lungs unless you
blow it out really really aggressively
like *heavy breathing* and then we should be pretty close and if you can't get it out just
stand on your head for a couple minutes
should be fine it'll just leak out
man awesome okay crazy so now that we've
demonstrated how heavy this gas really
is there's an experiment that I wouldn't
wanting to try with an aquarium filling
this gas up in an aquarium where it's
completely invisible and bringing out a
tinfoil boat this isn't a new experience
for the Internet
I was gonna say it'll be new to me but
I've never the new experience for us and
some we haven't tried before so awesome
let's go grab some tinfoil do it yes
alright guys so here is the setup, we have a pitcher full of dry ice and a cup of water, you know what happens when we mix water and dry ice
I'm trying to say is that we're going to
pour that vapor into this aquarium and it
should show us the levels of the gas now  normally dry vapor flows at the bottom
or I start pouring some sulfur
hexafluoride and observe the difference. you with me?
I'm with you they might not be with you
but I'm with you grant okay that's
actually good enough that's perfect
this is the time in my life where I feel
like a true mad scientist yeah you can
see the driest vapor flows right to the
bottom of the aquarium there's nothing
to stop it and it fills up the entire
aquarium with a dry spot all right that
should be good enough what I want to see
happen is if we really little bit of this
gas into the aquarium
like what's it going to do if anything
kind of hard to see anything happening
is a well now that it's in there though
if I pour in yeah try pouring a little
bit Warren see if there's any difference
oh it's really interesting is it's
floating at the top I'm going to say now
you'll notice it's not going down to the
bottom it's it's like three-quarters of
the way full
what's this invisible gas today this is
really unexpected I had no idea that
just that small bit from the balloon
would actually feel this aquarium to
course away but you can honestly see the
joy Roger gleaming up here so I think
what we're going to do is take this
white board cover the top and take a
little bit more gas and pump it in there
yeah and then we'll see if we can fill
up this thing completely to where it's
like literally at the top and we got
this dry vapor just flowing over the top
let's do it
Oh all right let's hold this right here
so you I'm thinking if we vent some in
here it'll push everything out there I
told you we had death
okay so now theoretically if that worked
we will have sulfur hexafluoride pretty
much filled this tank and yet we put in
a little more Drive safer we may be able
to see something on the top hopefully
yeah whoa it won't even get into the
aquarium at all
force field look at that yeah you can
you can see it almost like you're
pouring water into like pouring water
into like a tank of water where you see
it kind of dipping below the surface so
that it's popping back up that's making
kind of an eerie fog isn't it yeah you
know I feel like I've got some like
small water balloons around here we
should blow up some water balloon and
see what happens in there does it float
oh wow it does it does you're done yeah
like dip down just enough and then it
settled on the surface it's just
hovering there well it kind of stuck to
the side but still interesting so it
makes me wonder if we can get a balloon
to flow do you think something like a
ping-pong ball would be able to float or
do you think that'll be too dense
they would just hole I think wonderful
absolutely it's really good right what
do you guys think
push your comments below will a
ping-pong ball float on sulfur
hexafluoride
all right gas has been transferred okay
ping-pong ball there you go I'm actually
voting it's not going to work really
that's my vote all right Oh shame that's
just a little bit too dense yeah they're
a bit heavy that would be crazy though
if you could play ping-pong in midair
that would that would be nuts like if
you could actually spume oh that's cool
look at that that's awesome this is
flammable
it's non flammable okay actually
although I have a series what happens if
we give this into the sulfur
hexafluoride this immediately goes out
oh wow
and you can even see the remnants smoke
from the flame floating on top of the
sulfur hexafluoride level that we have a
people area that's correct yeah you can
see it bouncing around it's like a wave
it's wall without soap lirikl said
earlier it's completely not
what's next what are we gonna do now Oh
pick me pick me all right Matt can we do
that boat thing you talked about at the
beginning yes we've seen people do
little boats out of tinfoil and
basically the same thing we just did
with the balloon except with one small
twist let's just show you in just a
second so grab the aluminum foil and
let's see if we can make a boat hits me
with aluminum foil
thanks all right here it is this is our
best attempt question about this do you
think it's going to be wide enough to
displace enough gas to like compensate
for how heavy it is no I don't actually
I would love to be optimistic in this
scenario but let's be the crushing voice
of realism here this will not float
okay guys speaking of predictable make
your predictions now which boat is going
to float this one this one or neither or
both okay if you don't mind I'm going to
try this boat first and he has a higher
chance of success Oh No what the heck I
thought it was going to work their first
time did you I did yeah sorry and if I
never have oh you can folks this is
Jason's boat there you go
what are we doing wrong guys why can't
we get this to work other people are
doing it maybe our aluminum foil is too
thick I think it's a combination of just
the overall thickness of that
high-quality target brand and up enough
aluminum foil but also you'll notice we
have a lot of excess in our boat like I
feel like the optimum boat for this is
just going to be like very clean fold
not wrinkled at all because all of these
wrinkles are just adding to the surface
area the amount of tin foil that we're
using in this case thereby making our
boat heavier and heavier
that sounds spent time going before he
said there you go boom science drop in
knowledge
I mean really think a little slower so
you can see the fog is near the top here
yep we had our boat will it float oh we
are tremendous failures what do we go
from here and do we keep pushing to make
it work or do we just accept our destiny
and move on maybe we should build our
boat first we'll give that a chance to
settle down build a boat take the lid
off very carefully and try one more time
all right all right here we go I'm going
to set another boat another experiment
will it work the best camp
it was right there you know where I
still stand by the fact I don't know if
we have to tape it or what but it's
these little whole areas of the fold
where I mean it's a gas right and so
just like water just like air it finds
the way in wherever it can and in this
case I think we're we pulled it up the
wall yeah where it's all creeping in I
think you're right
and there's not really a lightweight
tape like if you add too much weight
it's going to sink right and if you
don't plug the holes it's going to say
this thing it's really a fine line
trying to figure out how to engineer
this thing yeah but that out of all of
them so far was that be playful
I just want to say even though we had so
much difficulty getting the tinfoil boat
to actually work it just goes to show
what you see isn't always what you get
there are a lot of variables that come
into play when you try this for yourself
go check out game theory it's a really
good family-friendly educational content
and you're going to learn something on
every episode it's true and we actually
have special episodes on game theory
with Grant exploring the Pokemon player
world on film searing we have us doing
some waterbending experiments that grant
helped us to do and on GT live our live
stream we actually did some flavor
manipulation which was pretty wild
messing with our taste buds so a lot of
what you like on this channel but over
there in science II getting even nerdier
and of course the big tanks in GD Nilo
932 for putting this request down in the
comments and go ahead and check your
youtube inbox GD Nilo 932 or sending 25
bucks No are you kidding for real gets
25 bucks 25 bucks man but most
importantly of all remember that's just
an experiment a random experiment thanks
for watching
quickly oh yeah there's definitely gap
there
you know what that effect isn't quite as
dramatic as I was expecting I was
expecting something a little bit heavier
as its medium dizzay about hey guys I
want to jump back in for just a second
to invite you to come follow me on
Instagram
I've got a very active page where I post
daily pictures and stories of behind the
scenes and every day's an adventure just
take five seconds right now to click the
link in the description to come follow
me on instagram at the king of random
I'll see you there